I'm sitting here with Mike Wales.
He is one of our front end developers.
How you doing?
>> Good.
So what are we talking about?
>> We're talking about getting things with no context whatsoever.
>> [LAUGH] >> Like this interview.
>> This interview.
Okay. >> So, have you ever been in a situation where someone has handed you
a whole bunch a code, written in a framework you've never seen before?
>> Okay. >> You've never seen this code itself before.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And you hardly know what it does.
And they give you some task to do.
>> Oh yeah, all the time.
>> All the, really? >> [LAUGH] Yeah, it's pretty common.
>> Tell me a little bit about the feeling behind that.
Like what, what does it feel like when someone hands you this big mess?
>> Yeah.
It's a daunting task at first because like you said,
they've handed you a big mess and you have no idea what's going on.
So you just got to, you kind of have to make a plan of attack.
And how are you going to figure out what's going on?
And how are you going to get the right amount of context to
accomplish the task that's been handed to you?
>> Yeah, I mean one of the things is it feels like a big mess,
not because it necessarily is but because you don't have that context.
>> It's just new to you.
Right? >> Exactly.
Yeah.
So how would you go about getting that context?
>> The first thing I would do is try and track down what libraries or
frameworks that application might be using.
And hopefully it's something popular or something well-documented.
And I would just dive into the documentation of that library or that framework.
>> Now, are you looking to get a lot of specific information, like
really become an expert in this framework or are you looking for a big picture?
>> No, not at all.
Yeah, just a big picture.
Just kind of where is stuff at in this framework.
What are the best practises that this framework establishes just so
I can figure out, because I mean I have this task I need to accomplish.
I don't have the time to sit here and learn a whole framework.
So just to kind of,
or where do I need to look in the application code to get this problem solved?
>> Yeah, and pretty much all organizational libraries and
frameworks are the same.
>> Right. >> I mean, they all have models.
They all have collections.
I mean, they all call them different things, right?
>> Right.
>> Like for example, Knockout calls them observable arrays rather than
collections, or something like that.
>> Yeah, my goal would just be to find out what does this framework call it and
where is it at.
>> Got it. So that's to enable you to figure out, in your code that you've been
given, where to look to implement the feature that you want to implement.
>> Exactly, otherwise I have to sit there and
read the entire application code, and who knows how long that's going to be.
>> All right, that makes sense.
So, what about if your framework, or
library, doesn't have documentation, or doesn't have good documentation?
>> Burn it all down and redo it.
No. [LAUGH] >> [LAUGH] >> Don't do that.
Don't do that.
>> I'm kidding-
>> Then you just have to, you have to spend the time to
read through the application code and, and just understand it.
And you should estimate the time required for
that task to now be like five times as much as your original estimate.
>> Mm. So legacy code can be pretty difficult.
>> Absolutely, if it's not documented well.
Yeah. >> Awesome. Well, thanks for sitting with me, Mike.
>> Mm-hm.